gift in mind and those leaks are from
the same source as were the leaks for
the previous episodes that turned out to
be quite accurate so again if you don't
want anything spoiled it's time for you
to close this video anyways part 1 or
should I say half of the fifth episode
ended in King's Landing with Cersei
promising to the nearest John and the
other lords that she will send her
troops north to support the living side
Winterfell is next starting of it sends
a Littlefinger Baelish says to her that
arias dangerous saying that she has some
evil plan which is why she came back
Littlefinger is still trying to get in
senses had as he has been trying this
whole season he wants to tear the Starks
sisters apart he's basically creating a
chaos to achieve his own goals
Littlefinger also says the sense that
that are evil used the letter against
her somehow Jagan stone is next Daenerys
and John with the rest of their team
have already ride the dragon stone after
they attended the huge meeting in King's
Landing there in the chamber of the
painted table where they're organizing
in the defense of the north Fiona and
John's speak about the Starks and the
Greyjoy's as well as about how it used
to be when they were growing up together
John asks if he will come with them to
the north on which Thea replies with no
I must rescue Yara first John says that
he should do that and wishes him luck
upon finding out from Euron DTR is still
alive and upon urine challenge him
during a huge meeting at the dragon pit
to come and get his sister Thea now
tries to rally the remaining Ironborn
left in Dragonstone so he could at least
try to save Yara
this is when the fight between the
leader of those remaining Garen born and
Theon takes place Theon seems to be
losing which is when he realizes that if
he loses that men will stay leader of
those Ironborn and therefore his chance
of saving Yara is lost after being
mocked and pretty much beer a nap Theon
gets back into the fight and beats that
Ironborn leader which results with him
forming a rescue party and heading out
to save Yara
back to Winterfell Sansa Gator sold the
Lord's from the north and front Vale
sensor than console area to come forward
arrow starts to worry that this is her
last day alive
something like sense added in sixth
episode when Arya confronted her Sansa
then says it's time to judge the grey
treacherous and betrayals that have been
done to the north and we will judge the
person responsible for them looking
straight at Arya sensor says you need to
tell me how many times you have betrayed
the north still looking straight at Arya
RA shocked and cannot ball
her sister is saying this to her sensor
says it again you need to tell me how
many times to have betrayed the North
Lord Baelish
at this moment sensor starts name all
his treacherous and betrayals over her
family as well as over the ruling House
of the veil sensor then pulls out a
leaner and steel dagger and asks him if
he recognizes it all finger says it
belonged to Tyrion just as he said to
her mother back in the first season but
Sansa knows it was his this whole time
next to senses bran who is the one that
has told her all these things Brandon
says you once told my father I told you
not to trust me
why Littlefinger is shocked since also
tells told the Lords present how he sold
her to the Bolton's Baelish realizes
he's pretty much done but still tries to
get his way out by telling them lies and
even asking for help from John Royce the
Lord who not only was a good friend with
Ned Stark but also the Lord who has
questioned the Littlefinger's intentions
the whole time Littlefinger is
desperately trying to convince other
Lords in his innocence and at this point
it looks pretty much pathetic this is
the moment in which this lake script
page is taking place census says when he
brought me to Winterfell you told me
there is no justice in the world
not unless we make it Littlefinger looks
at Arya Stark a petite executioner with
an elaborate dagger made of Valyrian
steel and the dragon bond he'll dead
bran handed over to re after
Littlefinger gave it to him at the end
sensor tells the Littlefinger thank you
for all your lessons Lord Baelish
continuing and most likely saying I will
never forget them
Littlefinger tries to talk with the lady
of Winterfell he says Sansa but doesn't
even have a chance to lie or manipulate
as Arya swipes the dagger across his
throat
Littlefinger starts to choke in his own
blood and falls to the ground holding
his throat and dies it says everyone in
the Great Hall watch him die and no one
moves a muscle to help him which is not
surprising at all Arya Stark will kill
Petyr Baelish with a dagger that
Littlefinger held to Ned Stark's throat
while betraying him while this dagger
also partly caused the war of the five
kings as well as the destruction of how
stark a bit later starts sisters will
have quite an emotional conversation
which is when the script page will take
place basically RSS the censor that
she's never going to be as good as she
is in the matter of ruling and also
means that she never could have survived
what census arrived sends on the other
hand says Daria that she is the
strongest person she knows their stay at
the store has best
since and Aria look out across the snowy
landscape or you look Sabbath her big
sister aria asks her sister are you'll
right since announced and replies is
just range in his own horrible way I
think he loved me she is clearly talking
about Littlefinger and his creepy love
towards her
Aria says you did the right thing censor
replies you did it
Denarius says I'm just you pass the
sentence you're the lady of Winterfell
since a glances set sorry I desks or
something on which are replies with nope
and I'm never going to be good as you
probably ruler or lady so I had to be
something else I never could have
survived what you survived censor
replies you would have you're the
strongest person I know
aria looks at her big sister again back
to King's Landing we have Jaime and
Cersei having an argument basically
Cersei promised to Daenerys and John day
she will send troops north to support
the living side and now she's revealing
to Jaime that she lied
Cersei reveals that she does not intend
to help against the army of the Dead and
also reveals her true intentions
she tells Jaime that she wants the night
king to kill the northern army center
allies and also says that she had
obtained an agreement with urine while
he pretended to be a coward who is
heading back to Pyke he actually went
with his iron fleet vessels to Hardin
bring the golden company to Westeros on
her behalf upon hearing out sources true
intentions Jaime will finally figure out
who his sister-in-law virtually is which
will result with Jaime finally leaving
sir C we see Jaime leaving King's
Landing and is on his way north he stops
to fix his golden hand and looks back to
the red keep which is when the first
snowflakes begin to fall on the capital
there's also a leaked script page of the
scene
there's written that Jaime writes north
looking behind him he's no longer in the
Leinster uniform he is no longer
commanding nor representing his house
Jaime's dressed like a cell sword
stopping his horse he pulls on a black
glow special designed for his golden
hand he notices a single snowflake
lending it continues he glances back at
something and at the high tower saw the
red keep either looking or going forward
never looking back again a long horseman
going north on the Kings Road then we
are going back to Winterfell and those
scenes to most likely be the best scenes
of the entire season bran is visited by
Sam and brain recognizes him
Brandon asks what he is doing there and
Sam tells him he needs to see Johnson
Oh breath says he also needs to tell him
a lot which is when sam asks bran what
he needs to tell John Brennan replies
with Johnny's not lets bastard but
Leanna's and drag our son born in Dorne
and his name is not John snow but John
sand in case you don't know every child
born out of wedlock use the special
surnames that are dependent on reaching
a child was born in surnames and that
marks them as a bastard is used in Dorne
where John was born and therefore branch
says that John's surname is not snow but
rather sand
anyways Sam tells brand that Johnny's
not the sand eater
revealing that he has seen it in record
that Rhaegar had his marriage with
Dahlia annulled and at some point of
time reoccurred married Liana
meaning that John is a Targaryen Sam
then tells brand that if he can see into
the future and past then he should go
see for himself this is a moment we all
have been waiting for a long time we are
finally going to see Recker Targaryen
brain goes into the past and sees the
wedding between Rhaegar and Lyanna stark
in a forest
well this flashback is happening the
scene switching back and forth between
Rhaegar with Liana and John with Danny
on the boat as the romantic scene
between Rhaegar and Lyanna takes place
we see John and then his romantic scene
as well John and Danny enter cabin
together in which they begin to take
each other clothes off as intimate
relationship between John and nurse
intensifies we see the scene in which
Liana is in the Tower of joy li ancestor
her brother Ned that the baby's name is
Aegon Targaryen Brandon says that Aegon
Targaryen aka Jon Snow is the legitimate
heir to the Iron Throne after he has
been mentioned in ten episodes of far
away finalists c rengar in a flashback
to be honest it's not surprising but
rather quite expected throughout the
season we've seen a couple of scenes
that either for share of this flashback
such as guilty discovering it in the
first place Prince Rhaegar and remarried
into someone else at the same time in a
secret ceremony in Dorne is that's a
common thing in the South these masters
end on the other hand they've also seen
a few scenes that clearly showed how
John is similar to his real father such
as this one he enjoys talking we all
enjoy what we're good at
night hunt now let's compare this scene
to a scene from the fourth episode of
the fifth season he told me rank I was
good at killing people like I never
liked killing this should be more than
enough for all of us to assume that
there will finally be an official
confirmation that not only that Rhaegar
is John's real father but also that John
was not born out of wedlock and
therefore he's not a bastard but rather
a Targaryen then we go to the wall or
more accurately twist watch her torment
and bury car we see the army of the Dead
the Blizzard following them and they
have almost reached the wall Thurmond
and Barrack are shocked as the series
went out of nowhere the night King flies
in on his Aryan the night King attacks
the wall with his Aryan focusing on one
particular part of it
bazarian starts melting it and as this
happens the wall starts to break apart
in a v-shape the gap in the wall is wide
enough for the army of the Dead to go
through the season finale ends with the
night king flying through the wall on
Missourian derek have guys detailed
review for the final episode of the
season that beside most likely being
accurate also seems to be the best
episode of the season and possibly best
episode yet produced